Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm
Jan and in this video we're taking
a deep dive into Army of the Dead's twist
ending, the alien origins of the undead,
secret cyborg zombies, and a second
mind-bending twist you might have missed.
Many thanks to State of Survival
for sponsoring this video.
Spoilers ahead so take care.
Army of the Dead kicks off with
a high-octane sequence that reveals
how the zombie apocalypse started.
"Gatekeeper, this is Mothership.
The Four Horsemen are on the gallop.
You are a go to open the stable door."
This "mothership" mention is the first tease among
many that Zack Snyder deliberately wanted to make
to the extra-terrestrial origins of the zombies.
There's also the fact that the payload the
convoy's transporting is exiting Area 51,
the classified US Air Force facility in Nevada
that's routinely associated with UFO conspiracy
theories in both pop culture and real life.
Playing on this, two bright white orbs can
be seen in the sky and they zoom off in the
direction of the convoy as the journey begins.
"All right, I'll say it.
It's an alien."
The alien origins of this apocalypse may
also be a nod to George Romero's 1968
genre-defining Night of the Living Dead.
In that film, scientists theorised that the
zombie outbreak could have been caused when NASA
shot down an explorer satellite to Venus that,
upon its return to Earth, was found to be
carrying an unusually high-level of radiation.
The otherworldly nature of Army of the Dead's
zombies is also hinted at in the name of the hotel
where they take refuge in Vegas, the Olympus,
a reference to Mount Olympus which in Greek
mythology was considered a heavenly
threshold and the seat of the gods.
And they're all led by the
original Alpha who created them,
Zeus, named after the king of the gods, whose
statue he sees when he arrives in Vegas.
The film's official press notes reveal
that Zeus's backstory is depicted on
the side of the Olympus Hotel.
The circular object in the middle
with light emanating from it,
with men and animals looking on,
may be hinting at the arrival of a UFO on Earth
that has unleashed some kind of zombie virus.
Alternately, it might be a pointing to
secret government experiments on aliens
or alien matter with the intention
of creating a new type of warrior.
After all, we do know that Martin's
secret mission was to capture a zombie
head for his boss Tanaka, who was in turn
covertly working with the US military.
Snyder has talked about giving the zombies a
kind of higher consciousness than we normally
see and then getting the audience to "feel
sympathy [with] or connect to the zombies."
Which is why he has scenes where they "nuzzle
each other [to reaffirm their emotional bonds]".
On top of that, we see these zombies
communicating with each other and,
like humans, they have a social hierarchy, with
distinctions between Alphas and Shamblers.
They even have rules and norms that people
like Lily the Coyote have been able to learn,
which is why she offers up the abusive Burt as a
sacrifice to them in return for a limited amount
of freedom to move around the city.
"They're smarter.
They're faster.
They're organized.
They won't mind us poking around..
..so long as we play by their rules."
Also next to the human-hybrid figure in
the picture is what looks like a woman
in some kind of luminescent bubble.
I wonder whether this is referencing Zeus's zombie
queen and the moment of her baby's conception,
perhaps even an allusion to it being some
kind of religious or spiritual experience,
such as the Virgin Mary's
visitation by the Holy Spirit.
This ability for zombies to become
pregnant, similar to humans,
is intriguing and Snyder says he
"had the idea from the beginning that
these zombies were going to embody an evolution,
[…] on their way to becoming something else,
not stagnant like the zombies we're used to."
By the way, Snyder also touched on the theme
of zombie babies in his first
undead flick Dawn of the Dead,
although he's said that the two films aren't
connected and, of course, the zombie baby in
that movie was conceived when its parents were
both still humans, unlike this latest film.
Snyder has also said that the ambiguity
surrounding the zombie origins in Army
of the Dead will be explored further in
the upcoming Netflix animated prequel
series "Lost Vegas" in which, he teases,
that we will get to see "zombies in space".
Another zombie detail you might have missed,
as you can only see them at very brief moments
in the movie, is the existence of what
appear to be robot or cyborg zombies.
The clearest example you'll see comes
when the team are fighting their way
through the casino floor and Raul shoots
a zombie in the head, revealing a glowing
blue eye and metal skull underneath.
You can also see another zombie with two
glowing blue eyes in the crowd at the Olympus as
Zeus enters with the corpse of his zombie queen.
Snyder has said this is supposed
to hint at two possibilities:
first, that the government could have placed
them among the zombies to monitor them;
or second, that they're
technology from another world.
Although Zeus and all the zombies he created
are wiped out when the government nukes Vegas,
the twist at the end is that one of his bite
victims Vanderohe did survive thanks to being
enclosed inside the exceptionally strong safe
underground when the nuclear bomb went off.
With Vanderohe discovering he's infected just
as he's about to touch down in Mexico City,
the zombie outbreak looks set to
spread to Mexico and likely beyond.
However, Vanderohe's fate was predicted
in a subtle way right from the beginning,
and I'm going to dive deep into that, plus
explain the mind-bending second twist you
might have missed, right after thanking
this video's sponsor "State of Survival".
State of Survival is a zombie-themed survival
strategy game available completely free
to download on both iOS and Android,
and thanks to an awesome new crossover
event with AMC's The Walking Dead, you
can now play the game as Daryl Dixon.
The game is set in the aftermath of
a deadly disaster, where you can form
alliances with other players, or build
and grow your own settlement solo to
defend yourself against the zombie hordes.
You'll need to build up your skills in the
game and recruit other heroes so you can go
up against the evil company Gigacorp which
unleashed the zombie catastrophe on the world.
The game has tons of rewards for dedicated
players and some great events like "Oasis
Guess", a daily quiz about The Walking
Dead and State of Survival where you can
win prizes including Amazon gift cards.
Walking Dead fans will also love the TWD
easter eggs hidden in every corner of the game,
and you can collect these by completing
different tasks or exchanging them with friends.
The game is full of many cool twists
and turns and features multiple game
modes so you'll never get bored.
For a limited time you can grab
a completely free starter pack by
using my creator code "FlicksSOS".
So download State of Survival for free via
the link below and use code "FlicksSOS" for
an awesome set of starter rewards.
OK, so the clue that Vanderohe would
become the last zombie survivor of the Vegas
outbreak was signalled via the Omega symbol on
his chest, which likely has several meanings.
First of all, given he's a philosophy graduate,
Vanderohe may be a member of the Omega Psi
Phi fraternity who are known to sometimes
mark their skin with the Omega symbol.
Omega is also the last letter in the Greek
alphabet, and given the abundance
of Grecian references in the movie,
it's a pointer to Vanderohe ending up as
the final zombie who survives this story.
Zeus was, of course, the first Alpha zombie and
Alpha is the first letter in the Greek alphabet.
And in the apocalyptic Book of
Revelation, the term Alpha and
Omega is also used as a title for God.
In addition to symbolising endings,
Omega can also symbolise a great step forward,
a hint perhaps that the zombie Vanderohe will
turn into could be an even stronger
or more advanced creation than Zeus.
After all, despite the protection from the
safe, it's possible some radiation from
the atomic bomb leaked in and affected
the way the zombie bite infected him.
And is that what he was hinting at
when he quoted Joseph Campbell?
"It is by going down into the abyss
where we recover the treasures of life.
Where you stumble, there lies your treasure.
To the ironic twist of the unknown."
Any weird atomic-related powers Vanderohe
might have gained could also be a possible
explanation for how he managed to survive
any ill effects from the bite for so long
that he was able to walk out of Vegas,
drive to Utah, and charter a private
plane all before turning into a zombie.
The Götterdämmerung safe may also be the source
of a secret second twist in the movie.
First of all, its name is significant
because it's not only the last cycle in
Wagner's epic opera, but it's also the
German translation of the Old Norse phrase
Ragnarok, aka the Twilight of the Gods.
In Norse mythology, Ragnarok is a
cataclysmic event leading to the
death of many gods and the renewal of the Earth.
"If I can open it, it will be either destruction
or renewal.
Death.. or rebirth."
"That's heavy, brother.
But I dig it."
That line from Dieter foreshadows his death at
the hands of Zeus and his zombies when he closes
the vault's door on Vanderohe who, by contrast,
will be figuratively reborn when he emerges.
And when Scott and Maria visit Dieter to ask
him whether he'll be able to crack the safe,
his answer reveals a clue to a
potential second twist in the movie.
"It's a doorway to another realm my friends
and providence has brought you to me.
We go through it together."
That line may explain a puzzling
moment later outside the vault when Dieter
discovers the remains of another team.
"There's another team of grave robbers."
"Is it another team, or is it us, Dieter?
I mean, look at them.
It's us.
It could be us in another timeline,
and we're caught in some infinite loop
of fighting and dying, fighting and dying..
And Tanaka..
the puppet master.
Devil.
God.
And we, you, me, Guz, and the rest of the team,
simply pawns in some perverse play where we're
destined to repeat our failures.
And finally, in some mind-bending,
ironic reveal...
it all begins again."
If you look closely at the skeletons
they really do seem to be wearing the
same items that the current crew have
been wearing throughout the mission.
There's Scott's red bandana, Maria's key
and necklace, and the colourful shirt and
metal chains that Peters wears.
What's even more strange is that,
in this movie, Maria is the only one of those
three who dies in the area by the vault.
Scott and Peters both die after the
helicopter crashes outside Vegas.
It's a very uncanny moment when you consider
what Vanderohe says about a timeline loop.
However, Dieter's earlier reference of the
vault being like a "doorway to another realm"
makes me think a potential explanation
is that when Vanderohe emerges from
the safe and the rubble in Vegas,
the atomic blast has somehow made him
turn up in an alternate timeline.
It's pretty crazy, but with the
placement of these skeletons and
Vanderohe's weird time loop monologue,
the movie seems to want to suggest there could
be some strange timeline shenanigans going on.
And it might not be a complete coincidence that
it was inside the vault where Snyder decided to
include a Justice League Snyder Cut easter egg.
The canisters on the shelf to the left of the
safe's door hold the actual reels
of footage that Snyder filmed for
Justice League, and spoiler alert,
in Snyder's version of that movie, the
Flash uses time reversal as a crucial plot point
to reverse Darkseid's mother box apocalypse.
So could Snyder be using the vault as a kind
of magical plot device to create multiple
timelines in an Army of the Dead multiverse?
Of course, Vanderohe's mention of an infinite
loop of fighting and dying may be hyperbole
on his part given he studied philosophy
and more of a foreshadowing of how his own
survival and infection means that although
the nuke should have ended the apocalypse
for good, the zombie plague will carry on.
That doesn't explain though where the skeletons
with the crew's clothing came from, unless that's
some elaborate ruse by Tanaka for example,
given he'd apparently already sent teams in
to the city before and given the fact he also
withheld the real purpose of the mission.
Let me know what you think
in the comments below!
So, what did you think of Army of the Dead?
And if you enjoyed this,
a thumbs-up and a share are hugely appreciated.
Coming up will be videos on Lucifer, Cruella, and
The Conjuring 3, so tap left for my next video or
tap right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!